hey this is presh tollwacker
If X Plus Y is equal to 12 what is the
minimum value of the square root of 4
plus x squared plus the square root of 9
plus y squared
I think hin and Aston for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
foreign
I will present two ways to solve the
problem first I will use calculus and
show the standard way to solve an
optimization problem
then I will show an incredible trick
that uses only geometry
so let's get started with Calculus
If X Plus Y is equal to 12 then Y is
equal to 12 minus X
so we have the square root of 4 plus x
squared plus the square root of 9 plus y
squared and we can substitute that Y is
equal to 12 minus X so this is equal to
the square root of 4 plus x squared plus
the square root of 9 plus the square of
the quantity 12 minus X
this is a function of a single variable
X
so we can solve this by taking the
derivative with respect to X
so we use the chain Rule and we have the
sum of two different things so it's
going to be a little bit complicated we
can then simplify this so we have x
divided by the square root of 4 plus x
squared minus 12 minus x divided by the
square root of 9 plus the square of 12
minus x squared we want this derivative
to be equal to zero
we now multiply both sides of this
equation by the product of the
denominators so this simplifies to be X
multiplied by the square root of 9 plus
the square of 12 minus X
minus 12 minus X multiplied by the
square root of 4 plus x squared this is
all equal to zero
so how do we simplify this equation
we move the negative 12 minus X multiply
the square root of 4 plus x squared to
the right hand side and then we Square
both sides so we get rid of the square
roots
now we're going to expand the binomials
and simplify I'm just going to skip over
all of these TDS calculations
now a nice thing happens that the X to
the four terms and x to the three terms
cancel out so we end up with just a
quadratic equation we have 5x squared
plus 96x minus 576 is equal to zero this
is easily factorable as 5x minus 24
multiplied by X plus 24 is all equal to
zero
so we get two solutions X is equal to 24
over 5 and X is equal to negative 24.
so we'll test these
so we have our function and we can test
the value at X is equal to 24 over five
this is f of x is equal to 13 and X is
equal to negative 24 we substitute in to
get something approximately equal to
60.2
now we look at the derivative we see
what its value is so when X is equal to
24 over 5 F Prime of X is equal to zero
when X is equal to negative 24 F Prime
of X is not equal to zero so this was an
extraneous solution when we squared both
sides of the equation so we get that the
minimum value is f of x is equal to 13
when X is equal to 24 over 5. wow
so now let's solve this with a trick
using geometry so we have X Plus Y is
equal to 12 and we want to minimize the
square root of 4 plus x squared plus the
square root of 9 plus y squared so how
can we turn this into a geometry problem
while we're trying to minimize a sum of
square roots and each square root is the
sum of squares
so we have the square root of 2 squared
plus x squared plus the square root of 3
squared plus y squared
so we can think about the hypotenuse of
right triangles
so let's make a length of 12
and now let's make one right triangle
or we have X on this base and the other
side is equal to 2. so the hypotenuse
will be equal to the square root of 4
plus x squared
now we can make another right triangle
and this base will be equal to Y
absolutely X Plus Y is equal to 12. now
its height is equal to 3 and then its
hypotenuse is equal to the square root
of 9 plus y squared
so at first it doesn't seem like we
simplified the problem at all how are we
going to minimize the sum of the lengths
of the hypotenuse well we're going to do
another trick let's reflect this green
triangle over
so now we have the same triangle just on
the other side of this 12 line
so now
we're going to imagine we want to
minimize the sum of these two lengths so
let's say we have the upper left point
is equal to a and the lower right point
is equal to B
let's say this point right here is equal
to C so we're trying to minimize the
length of AC plus the length of CB
now we can do this by using the
principle of a straight line
so this will be a minimum when ACB is a
straight line because that's the minimum
distance between points A and B
so if we draw the straight line between
A and B we know that c has to exactly be
right over here
so this will be the minimum length for
the sum of the hypotenuses
now in order to calculate this length
we're going to construct one more right
triangle so let's label this point as d
this will be a length of 3 and then DB
has a length that's equal to 12.
so we now calculate that a b squared is
equal to a d squared plus DB squared a d
is equal to 5 and DB is equal to 12. so
this is 5 squared plus 12 squared which
is equal to 169 and therefore a b is
equal to the positive square root which
is equal to 13. so that's the answer we
can minimize the sum of the square roots
by this right triangle and we get that
the minimum value is equal to 13. I
think that's a lot easier than doing all
of those calculations using calculus
amazing
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign